this is the seven hugs smart remote it's
a universal remote that connects to more
than 25,000 appliances and services in
your home the really cool thing about it
is that it runs on a proprietary indoor
positioning system that's able to
triangulate your location so it knows
exactly what you're pointing at when
you're pointing at it for example right
now I am pointing it at the Sonos
speaker and on the screen you can you
can see how you can change the volume if
you scroll up or down you can change the
song by clicking the arrows or you can
mute it when I point it at the lamp it
pulls up the hue app and here you can
change the hue by scrolling side-to-side
another really cool thing is that you
can point it out your window and it'll
tell you what the weather is like if you
pointed at your front door you can call
an uber or a lyft as our homes become
smarter that means we need a centralized
place to figure out how to interact with
all of the devices in our home it's in a
lot of ways kind of like pulling it up
on your phone but the really cool thing
about is that it's contextually aware so
anybody can just walk into the home
point it at something and they don't
have to worry about figuring out which
app to open it just just happens sort of
like magic
[Music]